there is some bad news for the west for
nato european union for ukraine for the
united states when it comes to what's
going on right now with russia in
eastern europe with this war in ukraine
the united states
has sent
kamala harris to go
and sort out the situation in eastern
europe
i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies and what is at stake at this
very moment
she couldn't she couldn't even get the
flank right they sent her to poland
uh which is very much not on the
northern part of nato that is on the
eastern part of nato she didn't know
where she was she did this this is a
similarity that kamala has with joe
biden
they don't know where they are they
don't know which end is up
the the
speech only got worse from there kamala
harris attempted to
to
rally the troops you know
you you once had ronald reagan show up
and say uh
you know mister he shows up to the
brandenburg gate mr gorbachev tear down
this wall you you once had uh uh winston
churchill speaking in america saying
from st
in the baltic to trieste in the adriatic
an iron curtain has descended upon
europe and and then
from kamala you get this
we all watched
the television coverage
of just yesterday that's on top of
everything else that we know and don't
know yet
based on what we've just been able to
see and because we've seen it or not
doesn't mean it hasn't happened
but just limited to what we have seen
i defy anyone to explain to me what that
meant
i defy anyone to try to translate that
gibberish into english you can't and
what i mean i mean this
i'm not really just joking about how
inept kamala harris is i mean this
sincerely
this is really bad news for ukraine
because it means that joe biden thinks
that ukraine is already lost
joe biden thinks that ukraine already
belongs to russia
because kamala harris is joe biden's
point person on failure
joe biden sends kamala harris to every
lost cause
to the southern border okay kamala's
going to be our point person on the
southern border now
that that's going to work out great
right this is an issue that's impossible
it's nothing's going to happen with it
and so here goes kamala how's that come
along has she fixed that i don't think
so he's sending her now every every
issue that he doesn't want to deal with
because he knows it's a lost cause
that's where he sends kamala so this is
unfortunate because
as of now
the russian invasion of ukraine has gone
much slower than a lot of people
predicted that it would the world has
rallied in a much more forceful way
against russia i think than putin
thought would happen there actually is a
chance for at least a negotiated peace
to maintain some semblance of ukrainian
sovereignty here
but you're not going to get that with
just abject weakness from joe biden and
you're not going to get that with kamala
harris showing up in warsaw to say we
know what we saw and we didn't see and
what we know we can do we can do if we
believe that we know that we can imagine
then we can do it here on the northern
side of nato in poland you know you're
definitely not going to get it there i
putin already knows that
the
geopolitical strategy of the biden
administration is is confused to say the
the least
but if he now knows that they don't even
know where poland is
uh you you're in a really weak situation
you need strength not weakness
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please please ring that bell subscribe
get the notifications and more
importantly even than that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show leave a
five-star review if you wouldn't mind
really appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]